difficile de savoir ce qui se passe
derrière chaque fenêtre après le
couvre-feu
cette nouvelle réalité fait craindre le
pire
c'est sûr qu'à l'heure actuelle on se
dit les femmes qui sont confinés avec un
conjoint violent qui subissent le
couvre-feu risque encore une fois d'être
davantage violentée selon un sondage
effectué auprès de 87 femmes qui ont eu
recours au soutien de ces maisons dans
le passé 79 % disent avoir vécu de la
violence conjugale pendant le
confinement 43% d'entre elles déclarent
que leurs enfants ont aussi été victimes
de violence soit elle n'avait pas
demandé dead où elle n'avait pas donné
suite à une demande aide parce que le
conjoint était là et c'était difficile
d'appeler ou parce qu'elle était
préoccupée par la pandémie ou parce que
les consignes la santé publique les
décourager il ya beaucoup moins de
demandes d'hébergement par exemple ici
ce qui nous inquiète nous avant que la
pandémie commence on avait un record de
femmes hébergées nathalie villeneuve qui
est directrice d'une maison
d'hébergement à saint jean sur richelieu
se dit inquiète des conséquences d'un
couvre-feu
c'est que c'est déjà difficile pour les
femmes de demander de l'aide
alors plusieurs d'obstacles le conjoint
qui toujours plus présent parce qu'ils
vont moins travailler à l'extérieur
le couvre feu le confinement les femmes
le savent quand arriva maison
d'hébergement les infections à l'école
une journée sur deux c'est plein
d'obstacles supplémentaires pour que les
femmes disent j'ai pas la force chantal
simoneau gère deux maisons d'hébergement
à québec principalement pour les
travailleuses du sexe une clientèle
aussi très vulnérables
je pense que les familles savent pas
qu'ayant loi de se présenter dans les
ressources y ont peur de se faire
intercepter par la police d'avoir des
contraventions qu'il ya beaucoup moins
une femme qu'est ce qu'on s'attendait
donc vu aussi envoyer un message aux
proches en disant rester à l'affût si
lou près de vous il ya une femme que
vous savez quelle vie de la violence
informez vous comment éleveurs
accueillez lâchez-vous même si on n'est
pas supposé recevoir des gens c'est un
cas de force majeure
ici marie michel lauzon radio canada
montréal